- Here is what you do if
you want to get ahead.
Success is about focusing
on what you want.
Not on what you don't want.
Nobody owes me.
No one owns you anything.
Wherever I am on my journey,
I'm loving it, okay?
I love the journey.
- He's the co-founder
and executive producer
for Real Social Dynamics.
He's been the creative
mastermind and main speaker
at hundreds of RSD seminars worldwide.
The foundation and principles
of Real Social Dynamics
comes from analyzing male
and female interactions.
He's Owen Cook or RSD Tyler
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips
and as always, if he's saying something
that's really impactful to you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(exciting music)
- Here is what you do if
you want to get ahead.
Completely cut out everything, okay?
Everything that doesn't support you.
Any type of food that doesn't
support you, don't eat it.
Every type of influence like television
or bull on the internet,
don't look at it, okay?
It's like Medusa, it
will turn you to stone.
Don't look at it.
When I see people looking at this,
I'm just like, you're out of
your mind, you're crazy, okay?
Don't look at it, that's
basically for failures, okay?
TV is like TV gossip.
Time wasting is the consolation
prize for being a failure.
If you're a failure, you just
get to sit there and go like,
ooh, American Idol,
man, who's going to win?
As soon as he said this
at the office today.
Okay, when I hear this, it's
like I'm hearing Charlie Brown.
I'm just like, what are you,
it's like I'm looking at a crazy person.
What the are you doing, okay?
Pretty much then what you do
is you limit your emotions down
to only the ones that will help you, okay?
So if you have an emotion
that doesn't help you,
you just get rid of it, it's gone.
Success is about focusing
on what you want.
Not on what you don't want.
Do you guys notice how
most of your friends
or people you know who are failures
perpetually focus on what they don't want?
You guys ever seen that?
Do you guys ever read comments online
maybe in my videos or say RSD Nation
where people are always
focused on their looks
and no matter how many videos I see
of me and Jeff pimping
it, they don't get it
that their looks are not an excuse?
You guys ever seen that?
Because they're focused on
what they don't want, right?
They're focused on what they don't want.
When they go to approach a girl,
they're not thinking of
having hot sex with her
or how it would be fun even.
They're just thinking
about not getting rejected
and how much it hurts and
how much they can't take it.
They can't take the pain.
They can't take the embarrassment.
They can't take the discipline it takes
to actually put themselves out there.
They can't take it
and so they focus on what they don't want.
Well, success is about
focusing on what you want
and not focusing on what you don't want.
Success is about punching
through the wall,
not punching at the wall.
You want to think of your journey like,
it's almost like you see that
light at the end of the tunnel
but you also want to think
of it like a narrow road.
You want to think of
success as a narrow road.
So you are walking that line of success
but you have a more
focused set of behaviors
than most people and you're
constantly course correcting.
So you're learning from where you up
and you're taking the lesson
and then course correcting again and again
and again and again.
Martin Luther King tried
to commit suicide twice.
You guys see what I'm saying here?
JFK went through periods of deep illness,
deeply deeply ill where
people thought he would die.
These types of things, right?
Winston Churchill went
through deep deep depressions.
So you can become one of those people.
It doesn't mean you're
going to become of them
because those guys are
in their own universe
but you can become somebody of great power
if you've gone through that
because you've been hardened.
Do you guys see what I mean here?
If you've been through that kind of bull
then if you've conditioned yourself
to pull yourself out
of something like that,
if the world gets all up,
all the other people,
they're used to happiness,
they're like, whoa happy.
They're like, my happy
world's falling apart.
My happy world is falling apart.
You're just like.
It's all good, baby.
Yeah, you don't care because
you're adjusted to it.
So you've taken conscious control.
Do you guys see what I mean?
Okay, so there's benefits.
Being a hard case newbie
means that you can be better
than any of the guys that had it easily.
It'll be harder to get but you
can excel to a higher level
than all the people
that were naturally good
if you choose to
but for you, it will
be a life of commitment
in the same way that a guy wants to get
kind of big in the gym.
If he's going to be big in the gym
and he's a hardgainer, little skinny dude,
he's going to have a
higher commitment level.
To get to that level,
you're going to have a
higher commitment level.
You're not going to get
to average as easily
and sometimes even
striving to stay at average
won't work for you because you slip back
so you have to really commit.
You have to take your foot
off the parking brake, man.
You have to burn the boats as
they say and just go for it.
As a hard case newbie, if you do that,
you can slowly build
those willpower muscles,
slowly reacclimate your
body to positivity,
build up friends, build up abundance,
build an amazing situation for yourself,
you'll do amazing, amazing things.
Another thing that you can
do is never ever complain.
When I see people
complaining, I'm just like,
what are you doing?
Your life is so short.
Are you really going to
sit here complaining?
Let me put this in perspective, okay?
I'm 34.
Okay, I'm 34, now in my 20s,
I didn't know that many
people that died, okay?
As you start to hit 30,
people start to die, okay?
I had a friend that died last week, okay?
People are just going
to start dying, okay?
I've also almost died
myself a couple times.
Who here in this room
has almost died before?
Put your hands up.
Look at that, look at that crowd.
Now, if that many people have almost died,
let me be a little morbid
and freak you out here,
how many people here weren't
here to put their hands up?
There's probably like
little ghosts of people like
I actually did die like right
in this crowd right now.
That is going to be you, okay?
You are going to be dead soon enough
so don't waste your
time complaining, okay?
Don't waste your time complaining.
It is a terrible, terrible idea, alright?
So basically what you want
to do is never be negative,
never complain.
I consider myself to be a
walking, breathing example
of the sort of things
that people talk about
in books like Napoleon Hill
Think and Grow Rich, The Secret,
any of those books where
somebody has a vision
of where they want to get
to and they walk that path.
The reason that this works for me
is that I have my internal compass
lined up so strongly at what I want
that every part of me is
moving in that direction.
Every single part of me.
So say that I go out to a nightclub
and I see some guy there who's
got girls all around him.
He's pimp, he's looking cool.
I'm seeing that and I'm looking
at it and you know what?
Who knows what his success is.
I don't really know
but there might be something about him,
the way he carries himself,
the energy that he has
and I look at that and I think,
I want to be moving towards that.
I'm meeting other people
that are good with women
and I'm thinking, I want
to be moving towards that
and I'm moving towards it always.
It's slow.
It doesn't happen overnight.
Very slow process.
But the years go by and you get there
and you really get there.
It's like the coolest
thing I could imagine
that you could have a vision
and you could realize it
just through lining up
your internal compass
and walking the path as
it unfolds itself to you.
The rich get rich, the poorer get poorer.
When I go out to the club in
Hollywood, people go, holy,
Owen, dude, I love your show.
Hey, man, come in with
our table and let me in
because I'm the pickup
artist who made it, right?
Meanwhile, the person that
wants to go in and learn,
no one wants to let him in.
They just sh him away like that.
No one wants to help the hard case newbie.
No one's going to help you.
Nobody owes you, okay?
'Cause you guys remember
the first thing I said
was that I knew I sucked.
I was willing to take my
time and make slow progress
but the other things I
said, nobody owes me.
No one owes you anything.
You have to get control of
what you have going on, okay
because people are attracted to abundance
and are repulsed by,
repelled and repulsed by scarcity, right?
So when you're someone with
no friends, no happiness,
you have a scarcity of friends,
a scarcity of happiness,
people feel a repulsion towards that
or repulsion away from that.
If you got loads of friends
and loads of happiness,
everyone wants to be your
friend all of a sudden.
You're going to downward
spiral or upward spiral.
The hard case newbie, he's
in the downward spiral.
He has to recognize he's
in the downward spiral,
take action to cut it off
and be willing to admit
that to get back on his feet
is going to take a long time.
It's like a poor country
in Africa for example
that has civil strife.
People are cutting each others'
arms off for diamonds and,
and little warlords fighting each other
and child soldiers and.
To put that country back
together is going to be difficult
but probably it's going to get,
a country that's up is
going to get more poor,
more ravage, more desolate
whereas a country that has
an abundance of resources
is probably going to get more
and more and more and more and more
because it's and upwards cycle.
So if you're in that downward cycle,
you have to look at
what's causing the cycle,
all the different elements
that are causing it.
Look at that and say, what can I do now?
I have always believed that
success is a challenge to obtain
and it is fleeting once
you have obtained it.
Success is challenging to get,
fleeting once you've obtained it.
I think you should never
take it for granted.
Never should you take success for granted.
Mediocrity is the norm.
I really really believe that.
And if you guys look at how I run RSD,
I mean, don't listen to my
words, look at my behavior.
Every week, I've got my new content up.
Every week, I've got the
new stuff I'm focused on.
I've got new projects on the go.
I'm banging it out.
I view it like a privilege though
I get to teach pickup as a career.
That's a privilege.
Now, most of you guys probably
think my life is like a joke
because you guys think that I'm like,
picking up hoes, teaching it,
bragging about it online.
That's probably what it looks like, right?
I get it, I would think that too
and that's a small element of it.
That's the best part but no,
I work my ass off at this.
Lot of people say, why do you still go out
usually seven nights
a week after 11 years?
Why do you guys think I
go out seven nights a week
after 11 years?
- [Answerer] To be good at what you do.
- 'Cause I appreciate that
I'm in the position I'm in.
I say it's a privilege, it's a privilege.
This is not some entitle.
That's a privilege to be in that position.
I've got a big audience here
to listen to what I
have to say about life,
success with women, success.
That's a privilege so I
take that very seriously
and I think that success
is something that is earned
and re-earned.
I think that in life, you're
climbing up that mountain
and you want to take breaks strategically
but people think that you
can climb up a mountain
and just kind of stay there.
Not really, I view it like
it's like a muddy mountain.
You climb up and you stay there.
You start to slide down
and there's a number of
reasons why that happens.
I'll talk about them today.
Does that mean you should
never take a break?
No.
I'm going to take a little time off
when I do my Miami events this year.
I'm going to sit there
eating sushi in South Beach
and stare at my belly button
and I'm just going to be great, okay?
And I'm looking forward to going out
to the islands in Hawaii this summer
and that's a long ways off
but when I'm suffering
hard with the workload,
that's something I can look forward to
and I'm going to sit beside a waterfall
and I'm going to sit there convulsing
while my body flushes the
year's worth of quarters
all out of it.
That's basically what I do.
Cool.
Of course I believe in taking a break.
I think you should spend time
with friends and take breaks
but I also believe that success
is something that has to
be earned and re-earned.
The world is a dynamic place.
The world is changing.
If you're not changing along with it,
you're probably being left behind.
It's so crazy how as an entrepreneur
or as somebody even who in their career
wants to be at a high level,
you have to like boundary
off so many behaviors
and influences that other people let in.
So essentially somebody at a high level,
they've just made the choice to say, hey,
if there's somebody who's overly dramatic
or disruptive in my life,
maybe you have to let them go.
It's super sad.
And if there's foods that are depleting me
or habits that are depleting me
or things that are making
me late or not on point
or not have my life together,
I have to let those go
and essentially, so a lot of
it is creating those boundaries
and what's funny then
is people who are maybe
not quite at that level,
they wish they could hang
out with people at that level
but they don't realize this like
it's not that that person's at
a so called higher level than you.
They just have stronger boundaries
and if somebody with less boundaries
is coming into that
circle, it's like, hey,
we'd love to have you here
but just work on your
boundaries a little bit
and we'd love to have you here, right?
So it's like people think that
other people are holding them down
but really actually, a lot of the time
I think they kind of feel bad for them
and hope they can do better.
Everybody who's at the top
is hoping to see other people come up
so there can be more cool
people to kick it with.
I actually chose to end off this video
pointing out the very
tall Rockefeller Center
to make the point about how
when you start to develop yourself,
it can oftentimes make you
feel even more insecure.
Alright, so lot of time,
I'll bring a friend of mine to the gym
and let's say it's a girl,
I'll bring her out to the gym
and she already feels
really hot about herself
but as she goes to the gym,
she begins to see her weak spots.
She begins to actually
realize how far she has to go
and paradoxically,
the very act of actually improving herself
makes her feel even more insecure.
You'll see the same thing when guys
actually try to get a
little bit of money going
or let's say that they try to learn
to be good with girls, right?
Let's say you actually
thought your money was okay
and then you start improving
your cash situation.
All of a sudden, you realize,
damn, if I want to get
a good business going
or I want to get my career
going with some good momentum,
I have a lot further
to go than I realized.
Likewise, as far as girls go,
most guys actually walk
around thinking like,
they could win any fight,
they could pick up any girl
but when you actually go and try to do it
and you realize how much you suck,
it winds up making you
feel even more insecure.
So just remember that the fact
that you are trying to improve yourself,
it's a paradox between
self-improvement and self-acceptance
because the very act of improving yourself
sometimes can make you
feel a little bit bad.
What's the frame that I come from then?
How do I do all the self-improvement stuff
and not feel terrible?
Well, what I do is I
come from a basic frame
and the basic frame is I'm already awesome
and I'm just enjoying my journey
of becoming even more awesome.
So I remember back when I
was first teaching bootcamps,
one of the first ones I ever taught
was here in New York City.
I didn't really have a lot of students.
We didn't charge a lot of money
and I probably wasn't the best teacher
so you might not have want
to be at that bootcamp
but the point being
was I was teaching
bootcamp in a Starbucks.
I'd sneak into an HIV clinic
and say that I had HIV
or we'd break into a school building
and do it on milk crates.
I'd be doing seminars
in those environments
and if you would have asked me
if I thought what I was doing was cool,
I'd say yeah, it's cool.
Right now, I might teach a
four or 500 person seminar
at a hotel.
You ask me if I think it's cool.
I say I think it's cool.
Someday, I could be teaching
a 5000 person audience
in a big auditorium somewhere
like some kind of convention center
and if you ask me if I think
it's cool, I think that's cool.
And if I was to run the whole damn planet,
I'll think that's cool too.
Wherever I am on my journey,
I'm loving it, okay?
I love the journey because
as far as I'm concerned,
the golden era is now.
The golden era is the present moment
and wherever I am, right,
if you're asking me now,
oh, did it suck when you taught
the programs back at Starbucks?
No, it was awesome.
I was already awesome
and enjoying my journey
to become even more awesome, right?
And someday, if I'm teaching 5000 people,
you say, oh teaching 500 people,
was that too small of a crowd for you?
I'd say no, I was just
enjoying my journey.
I was awesome, I'm just
enjoying being on the path
to becoming even more awesome.
I understand that cultures
brainwash you all the time
to desire completion
and this could be a 10 hour
seminar on this one topic,
how, literally how society
brainwashes you to think
that there will be completion.
Yeah, there's no one trying to control you
but just the way that society works out,
again, it's trying to be like,
the classic example that you'll hear
in zen or stuff like that
is you finish kindergarten,
you go to grade school.
Finish grade school, go to junior high.
Finish junior high, go to high school.
Theoretically, go to college,
get a job, get promoted,
retire and then the end is you die
and yeah, there is no completion
because you have to understand.
In the world, sort of like
a simple way of putting it,
very simple, overly simple,
there's the wolves and the sheep, okay?
Again, it's a very overly
simple way of putting it.
And the sheep again in
one way of looking at it
among a million different ways you could
are the people who think
there's going to be completion
and they are given a script by
the wolves who then eat them.
Okay, that's sort of the gist of it.
(dramatic music)
The reason why, there's
many different reasons why
we all want to be told what to do
and a lot of it can come
down that human beings are,
we have hierarchy, we
respond to hierarchy.
We come from tribes so that
there's many different reasons
that we all wish that we
could be told what to do, okay
but I'm going to focus on one
reason here in particular.
What I'm going to say to you, we're
going to put the microscope on
this one particular reason.
The reason why I think
that we all wish we
could be told what to do
is because we're all tired
and we're all scared.
Okay, I'm going to say that again.
We're all tired and we're all scared.
(dramatic music)
And because we're tired and scared,
we just wish somebody will
tell us it's going to be okay
and just give us a direction.
Just please give me a direction.
The wolves eat the sheep
and you got to realize that
there is no completion.
There's no completion here.
And the world is always changing.
Life is always moving.
From out of disorder comes order.
Out of order comes disorder.
Societies thrive and implode.
Relationships go awesome
for a while and dissolve.
Friendships are tight and end.
Relations between man and
woman are hot and passionate
and could potentially end
or if you follow certain rules,
you can make them last longer
and certainly you do
have a degree of control
and that is why if you learn business,
you should actually learn
how good business works.
If you lean pickup and relationships,
you should learn how that works
and you can definitely stretch things out
and create a robust structure,
not a fragile structure
that's always falling apart.
When you're in a state of mind
where you have complete self trust
to respond to any situation
or to make decisions,
to be a decision maker
in the face of vagueness
ambiguity, to be a wolf,
that is a higher level of consciousness.
That's like a different
vibrational frequency
as new age people would call it.
You're more awake and the reward
is the state of mind and
the person who you become.
Realize that the wolves of the world
simply embrace the ambiguity.
Be the wolves, not the sheep.
Realize that there never is a completion.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Sam Mac asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What did you learn from this
that you're going to apply
to your life or to your business?
Please leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
And finally, I want to
give a quick shout out
to Antoine Clerc-Renaud.
Thank you so much, Antoine
for picking up a copy of my book
and sending that amazing tweet.
I really really really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- If you look in the mirror
right after a killer night
or if you look in the mirror
right after an amazing meditation session,
what you'll find is you
really like the way you look.
It's almost like your face relaxes
and you have this kind
of look in your eyes
that just makes you attractive.
Meanwhile, if you're kind of insecure,
it just looks so different in the mirror
and that's because perception
of yourself is so subjective.
It's incredible, the most
beautiful person can feel ugly.
The ugliest person can feel beautiful.
It doesn't mean that you
shouldn't go to the gym.
It doesn't mean that
you shouldn't dress well
but rather you must
manage your self image.
In my experience, the guys
that are most tortured
are always the guys that are almost
the societal standard, right?
So it's like, it's that guy
who's five eight, five nine
who's so tortured that he's not six feet
because he almost made it
and every time he looks
in the mirror, he's like.
Like that, right, trying to imagine
that he looks a certain way, right?
And those guys get tortured.
Conversely, a guy who's
like say five five.
I got buddies that are
like five five, five four
or even five two.
Those guys oftentimes are
the most comfortable dudes
with themselves that you've ever seen
and the reason why is because
they're in non resistance.
There's no possibility
of lying to themselves
that they're six feet.
Sitting there in the
mirror going like that
is not going to do anything for them
so they just let go, accept
themselves, have fun,
have successes, build on it and love life.
If you can't change your thinking patterns
and your thinking patterns are all up,
rise above consciousness
as Eckhart Tolle has said.
Become present to the moment.
You don't even need to
change your thinking patterns
if you're present to the moment.
There's a major reason why Eckhart Tolle
is the most profound influence in my life.
For me to change my thinking
patterns is so difficult.
It is so hard.
The only way that I can fix
it is to go above thought.
Do you guys see what I'm saying here?
It's that up.
See, for a lot of you guys
who have a more positive
thinking pattern autopilot,
it's actually harder for
you to become present
'cause you like your thoughts
but then when they become negative,
it's harder to deal with
because you're used to your thoughts
and you're attached to them.
For somebody like me, it's
very easy to be present.
Can you guys guess why?
What happens when I stop being present?
- [Answerer] Feel bad.
- Say I'm up here nice and present
and then I go back down to the thought.
Ah, what the?
Like that, right?
It's like say that you got hit
in a bunch of car accidents
and your spine's all up
but if you maintain perfect
posture, you'll be good.
You'll actually have better posture
than someone who has average
posture or even good posture
'cause the accident forced
you to have perfect posture.
So if you're a hard case newbie,
the hope for you is that you can actually
become better than the
guy that has it average.
Anthony Robbins says the
enemy of the best is the good.
So if you use the leverage,
that your situation is so up and so lame
and you use that as leverage,
you'll wind up better than most guys.
People can look at me and
it almost pisses them off.
It's like, that guys gets
results, I'm pissed, right
and it kind of pissed them off
and then they got to deny
it to themselves and stuff.
Yeah, they can even see videos of it.
That's an actress.
It can't be.
He's uglier than me and he's got a girl?
Actress, right?
No, dude, you just didn't go out.
I did and you didn't.
I've actually thought
sometimes of creating a video
called What I Did While You Didn't Do It
or What I Was Doing While You Were,
no, no, I was thinking of calling it
What I Was Doing While You
Were Doing What You Were Doing
and I was going to like
enact the whole thing.
So I'd show like what you
were doing like watching TV.
Like this, what I was doing
and me just kind of
hustling through my life
going through my boring
little menial repetitive tasks
that I do every day
that improve me 0.00001%
and that add up over time.
I really think I should
make a video of myself
just going through my day
and just show me doing it every day
so people can see the menial, slow,
boring nature of progress
because for every public victory you have,
you have a private victory.
For every kickass video I put up online,
there's those hundreds of
hours that I spent at home
looking at my video footage,
looking at other speakers,
comparing it, contrasting it
and learning how to be a better speaker.
For every hot seat
video that you see of me
where I do some epic that blows your mind,
there's all that time
that I spend going out
and doing menial little bull approaches
again and again and again
and then going home and
looking at what I did
and how I could improve it and on and on.
For every kickass freaking out
bootcamp student that I have
that love the program,
there's those 50 weekends a
year that I went out and taught
and learned every little
nuance of the thing
again and again and again for a decade.
So that's kind of like
what success is like.
I hope that I provide an example of a guy
who is untalented, funny looking
and shouldn't be able to do it
and is stunting on all your faces and,
and that you can see that and say,
oh, if that little dweeb
can do it, I can do it.